>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Karen Jaffe: Welcome to
the Books and Beyond, Young --
Program for young people sponsored
by the Center for the Book
and the Young Readers Center.
I'm Karen Jaffe, head of
the Young Readers Center.
And I'd like to start by welcoming
our very important guests,
students from the District
of Columbia
and when I say your school
please raise your hands.
Friendship Collegiate
Academy Public Charter School,
Cesar Chavez Public Charter
School for Public Policy,
Thurgood Marshall Academy,
Gonzaga College High School,
Stewart Hobson Middle School,
and Washington School for Girls.
Let's everybody give a hand.
[ Applause ]
>> Karen Jaffe: I'd like
also to take a moment
to thank Kathy Wineburg,
a consultant to the Young
Readers Center for the second year
of our teen board program.
The idea of this event
essentially came from Kathy
and my very able assistant
to the YRC, Kahim Mohammad.
We're pleased to have
representatives from two
of our teen board schools,
Cesar Chavez and Stewart Hobson.
We also want to thank the rest
of our staff and volunteers,
without whom we could not
have produced this event.
So, please if you're with
the YRC raise your hands
so everybody can see you.
And we want to thank the
publishers of All American Boys,
Simon and Schuster for sending
the authors Jason Reynolds
and Brendan Kiely.
Both Jason and Brendan
are established writers
of teen literature.
I'm not going to steal
their own description
of the collaboration they produced,
except to say that this book
about race and police brutality
was inspired by many true
and recent events in too many
cities around our country.
And since this event is
being held in a library,
I want to take the liberty
in deference to the teachers
and librarians in the room to
reference an important Black author
by the name of Ralph Ellison,
whose short story Battle
Royal became the --
which became the first
chapter in his very famous book
from 1952, "The Invisible Man".
Was included in the storyline
of All American Boys.
So when you get back to
the classroom or even home
or in the library after
reading Jason
and Brendan's book you
might want to check
out "The Invisible Man" as well.
Two important housekeeping items.
This program is being
videotaped, you will have a chance
to ask questions later
and the authors will
explain how that will work.
Essentially what's going
to happen is you have cards
in front of you, and pencils.
As the program goes along you might
think of a question, jot it down.
You have two options; you can put
it in a basket that will be passed
around to pick up the
questions before we start.
And, you also have an
option of raising your hand
and speaking directly into the mic.
So, you can decide when that
time comes which will be
at the end of the program.
When the program is over, I
know we haven't started yet,
but please remember I will
call the schools as you exit.
Not everyone will get up and walk
out at the same time,
that's impossible.
So, I will call the school and
you will exit when I call you.
And lastly there's some schools
that have not picked up your books.
They are at the table
right outside here
where the public book
signing is taking place.
So, educators if you've
ordered a bag
of books please pick them
up after the program.
And now it is my honor to
introduce Jason and Brendan.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Jason Reynolds: So
with that -- you all good?
Everybody good?
>> Yes.
>> Jason Reynolds: All right.
So it is a -- I'm good?
Here's the thing, my name is Jason.
And to explain sort of what brought
me to this book, what brought me
to this book; I'm going
to tell you a quick story.
1998, all right?
So how old are you all?
Some of you all --
when you all born?
[ Cross talking ]
>> Jason Reynolds: So
none of you all were born.
None of you all were born.
But anyway, I was born.
I was alive.
1998, right?
Here's the deal.
Me and my homey's, it's
like four of us in the car.
There was a car back in the
day called a Nissan Stanza;
none of you all know what it is
because they don't
make them anymore.
You know, it was a Nissan Stanza.
What did it look like?
>> Like a little car.
>> Jason Reynolds:
Like a little car.
It's like -- it's sort
of like a car.
>> Jason Reynolds: It's like a car.
The Nissan Stanza was basically
like this strange little car
that they made back in the day,
but it was also sort of like a van,
sort of like a truck, like a
weird little vehicle, right?
And it had a sliding door on one
side, but it was only like --
it was tiny little car
with a sliding door, right?
Very strange.
Four of us are in the car.
We're riding down 23rd and Parkway.
You all know where
23rd and Parkway is?
Around there right?
All right.
So I'm from here.
I'm from your neighborhood.
I'm from Wheeler Road,
all right, right?
All right, so we riding
down 23rd and Parkway.
It's the middle of the day.
I'm thinking like maybe
3:30, the music is blasting.
We playing something crazy.
I can't think of what the song was
now, but it's like the equivalent
like in today's time
which I would be playing,
like Drake and Future, or whatever.
Like something just wild, right?
We blasting it.
And we get to a yellow light,
as the light turns yellow
as we're approaching it.
And my homey who is driving
drives through the yellow light,
right and makes the left turn.
Technically he didn't
break no law, right?
He makes the left turn,
we see the sirens.
Woot, woot.
Now everybody in my neighborhood,
everybody in my neighborhood
already knows what time it is.
We were all raised to believe
like listen, "You ever get pulled
over by the cops, yes sir,
no sir, hands up", right?
My hands on the wheel, everybody
doing what they're supposed to do.
The cop walks over to the car.
Remember there's four
of us in the car.
He walks over to the car and he says
"Let me get your license
and registration".
My buddy is like "You why
we being pulled over"?
The cop is like "Well
you ran a red light".
My ma is like "It wasn't
a red light.
The light was yellow".
He's like "Doesn't matter; give
me your license and registration".
My friend can't find the
registration to his car.
Now remember there's four of us.
There's two people in the front
and two people in the back.
Now the guy in the back seat,
behind the passenger side is one
of your homey's who is
like kind of stupid, right?
You know everybody has the one
friend you're like "Dog", like --
it's like that guy, right?
[ Laughter ]
>> Jason Reynolds: You
all know this guy, right?
So, so here's what happened.
So here's what happens.
So here's what happens, right?
We look -- we turn
around to our homey
and say "Listen check behind the
seat in the pocket behind the seat
and see if the registration
is there.
If it is, don't open the door.
Just pass it to me and
I'll pass it to the cop".
The cop has walked back to
his vehicle at this point
to run the license and do all
this, that and give him the time
to find the registration.
So we're all digging through the
car, digging through the car.
Finally, the dumb one, right?
He reaches in the back pocket,
he pulls out, he's like "Yo,
I found the registration".
Remember it's a sliding door;
this car has a sliding door.
I don't know -- minivans are
really quiet these days, right?
But like back in the day when
you opened a sliding door it was
like hearing a lion's roar, right?
You opened the door
there was so much noise.
So, he opens the door
and literally a second
into opening the door the
cop is like with his gun out,
like gun in the car in our faces.
Now here's the thing,
let's be clear.
I'm not necessarily upset about
the fact the cop drew his gun
because my home boy opened the door
and that was a ridiculous thing
to do, and so the cop
obviously went on the defense.
But what happens next is
ridiculous, true story.
What happens after my friend
opens the door, the cop tells him
to close the door after
we're all scared to death
because the gun is in our faces.
We sit in the car for
five more minutes.
The next thing you know
there are four cops, right.
Four cop cars pulling up behind us.
They all come over to us.
They say, "Do you have any guns?
Do you have any drugs"?
We say "No, we're coming
from high school.
We're coming from our school.
We have no guns, we have no drugs.
This is our neighborhood.
We're just trying to get home;
we've done nothing but
run a yellow light".
The officers say "I don't believe
you, everybody out of the car".
Five minutes later we're all
out -- there's four of us,
all out of the car with
face down, we're handcuffed
and they tear his car apart.
I'm talking like everything, tear
the seats out, looking for --
looking for something
that's not there.
Right, they took everything
out of his glove compartment,
they look under everything,
they empty out his trunk,
put everything on the street.
They pull everything out
of the car and put it all
on the street while we laid there
on our stomachs in our neighborhood
with our friends walking
by, "Yo what, what's good?
What's happening", this
that and the third.
And finally after like
10 minutes of this,
20 minutes of this they
don't find anything
of course because we're innocent.
They uncuff us and tell
us to be on our way,
leaving all of our
stuff on the street.
They all get back in their cars
and they drive away, right?
True story.
It shook me because it was
the first time that I realized
that oh man, it's real out here.
My older brother had
gone through it.
A lot of my other friends
had gone through it.
But it was the first time that I --
it could have been
much worse, right?
Anything could have happened.
Some of its home boys fault
for opening the door, right?
But the rest of it was
totally unnecessary.
We hadn't done anything but
run a yellow light, right?
I've got other friends who have had
their teeth kicked out, I've had --
I mean I have tons of stories,
some of which I'll share
with you guys another point.
But that's what brought
me to this book.
That was sort of my own
interaction as a young person.
In this neighborhood, from D.C.
as a young person in my experience
with the police officers
when I was your age.
And so when I sat down to
write this book that's sort
of what I was brining
to the table, right?
I remember what it felt like.
I remember what it was like
to have your parents --
how many of you all had the talk
with your parents about what to do
if you ever have an
interaction with the cops?
And most of you all aint' even --
some of you all in high
school, some of you all aren't.
That's a lot of people.
So, young age to have that talk.
And I was around your age
when my mom gave me that talk.
So --
>> Brendan Kiely: So,
I'm Brendan Kiely
and you can remember the
pronunciation of my last name
in a corny way, because
it's Kiely like smiley.
And I come to this book
with a different angle.
I'm from Boston and
don't hold it against me.
And I, too have two ways into this.
I too had interactions with the
police when I was in high school.
I too drove a car, actually
a minivan with a loud door.
It was maroon, it was a Chrysler.
I too drove around with a bunch
of friends, goofing around.
But I feel a moment
of pain as I begin
to share how different my story is.
And I had two incidents.
But the one that I want to share
is one where I did something wrong.
I was speeding 30 miles
over the speed limit.
That's insane, right?
>> Jason Reynolds: In a minivan.
>> Brendan Kiely: In a minivan.
It's insane.
Don't do it.
And I got pulled over in my minivan
with a minivan full of friends.
And I too didn't know
where my registration was.
I knew what my license was.
I didn't even know what
a registration was.
And my friend Adam, in the front
seat next to me was basically saying
"It's in the glove
compartment or somewhere",
like "You should know
this, you drive".
Finally we found it,
gave it to the cop.
The cop asked me to
step out of the car.
I get out of the car.
The cop did give me the third
degree, "Where's the marijuana,
where's the marijuana",
blah, blah, blah.
Didn't have any of that.
That wasn't part of the process.
And I explained, "Oh I'm nervous,
I'm just driving kids home.
We were supposed to go for ice
cream but that didn't work out.
The mini golf place was closed.
Oh my God, I'm just so scared".
And the cop said, "Look I'm going
to let you go with a warning".
Right? No, that's the
right thing to say.
What? It's crazy.
It's crazy.
And so I want to, I want to come
to this project All American Boys;
I want to come to this
project being really honest
about those two differences, right?
I think it's important
for us to think about this
as a piece of literature.
To think about the characters
involved in this book.
Jason wrote Rashad's narrative;
I wrote Quinn's narrative.
There are two narratives.
There are two kids living
side by side in the same city.
And their lives are so different.
And I wanted to come to
this project because I want
that to be a conversation that we're
all having, an honest conversation
that we're all having
and a conversation
that we can start having
in our classrooms
and hopefully we can start having
some larger conversations out there
in the rest of the world as well.
Because I also worked
as a high school teacher
for a number of years.
So, I recently have
stopped teaching.
I hope to go back because
I really miss it.
And as I looked around my
classroom, I see all these kids
and I taught kids from
all over New York City.
I lived in New York City
for the past 15 years.
So I taught kids from
all around the city.
And it was really difficult
to think about how these kids
in the same classroom are having
such different experiences.
And so I come to this
project wanting us
to really have an honest
conversation
about those different
experiences, does that make sense?
It makes sense, yeah.
So let me clarify because I
am still a type A teacher.
You do have those note cards;
you do have those note cards.
We do want to make sure we have a
lot of time for questions, right?
And if anyone feels brave and just
wants to speak into a microphone
and ask a question, great.
But if you feel like you have a
question that you don't want to say
out loud but you still
want to have us answer,
that's what the cards are for.
So you make sure you write that
down, get it into the basket
as it gets passed up and we'll try
to make sure we address it, okay?
>> Jason Reynolds: One of the things
that a lot of people always want
to know is how did
we write the book?
Right? How did this happen?
Why did the two of us decide
to sit down and do this, right?
The question comes up pretty
often, is something that we always
like to talk about
because it's important.
You guys remember Trayvon Martin.
You guys remember what happened
with Trayvon Martin, right?
So when Trayvon Martin happened
the two of us were on tour,
this is a little while ago.
We were on tour for other books
that we were traveling
the country talking about.
And then Trayvon happened, and
at first listen here's the truth.
I had just met this dude, right?
And coming from where I
come from it took a minute
for me to like trust him.
Because I wasn't used to sort
of having someone close to me
that wasn't black, that
wasn't from my neighborhood,
that didn't know my family,
that didn't know my way
or my environment understand
or even want to talk about any
of the experiences that
I had as a young person.
Any of the drama that we see
sometimes, if you growing
up in Anacostia, if you growing
up in some city, if you growing
up in the [Inaudible], right?
Like if you're growing up in any
of those neighborhoods, right?
So it was tricky for me at
first because it was like
"Dude you're not even going
to understand the way I feel
when it comes to Trayvon
Martin", right?
The way my mom feels.
Right? My mother called me
crying when Trayvon's verdict,
when the verdict happened
and George Zimmerman walked
and was found innocent.
My mother called me crying because
she felt like that could be my kid.
That could have been
my two sons, right?
All the kids in the neighborhood
that we grew up with, right?
And so the two of us
began talking about it
and I realized he was
as angry as I was.
A different kind of anger, right?
He shared the anger in the loss
of a child, he shared the anger
in a not-guilty plea, but he also
had a different kind of anger
that I think is necessary
for you to speak about.
And then what happened, as time
went on is, Mike Brown happened.
We all know Mike Brown, right?
We all remember the
Mike Brown story.
So when the Mike Brown story
happened that's when we realized,
and all the stories
in between, all right.
Let's not forget that there are
hundreds of stories in between
that happened before Mike Brown.
And when Mike Brown happened
the two of us sat down --
well he came to me actually, right?
And he said, "Look we
need to do something.
We need to write something".
And because Mike Brown, your age.
Trayvon, your age.
This ain't about us, right?
I'm in my 30's.
It could happen to me.
But who it's happening
to most often, kids.
>> Brendan Kiely: That's right.
>> Jason Reynolds: Our kids.
And so I want you to talk a
little bit about your indignation
about why you felt like
this was necessary.
>> Brendan Kiely: Yeah.
so it -- it was an honor and a
privilege to go on tour together.
To begin having these
conversations, right?
To begin having conversations
about racism.
about the structures in place
in our society that help
reinforce this racism.
And as I began following these news
stories, last year in particular.
It became really important
to me to think
about how do we -- so we're artists.
That's our bread and butter,
that's our soul, we're artists.
So we want to respond in some way.
But how do we respond in a way
that is honest, about this --
about the reality of the
lives of so many people?
And maybe the most honest
way to do that would be
to do something in partnership.
Because I was boiling.
I mean when we met
that first time to talk
about it, I mean it was like --
>> Jason Reynolds:
You were angry; yeah.
>> Brendan Kiely: I mean I
don't want to pound the table
because I don't want
to spill water on you,
but it was like table
pounding angry, right?
It was table pounding angry.
But part of that anger, part of that
anger isn't just that this happens.
Part of that anger is that it's so
unjust, the imbalance in our society
about who it happens to and
who it doesn't happen to.
So, that makes me mad as
a White person, right?
Because I think about
White privilege and I think
about how easy it is
for me to look away.
How easy it would be for
me to say "Not my problem".
Right? But it is my problem.
And that's part of what my anger
was about, is about finding a way
to say how can we get more of the
larger society across the country
to say "yes, this is in
particular also a White problem".
White people have to own this.
So, I came into the project
with that kind of anger.
But not wanting to just you
know, bang tables all day
because that's not going
to do anything, right?
So we wanted to create
something productive,
and so we wanted to
create this book.
>> Jason Reynolds: For sure.
Let me ask you all something,
how many of you all
are artists in any way?
All right, don't scream out.
What you do?
What's your art?
You draw, all right.
What you got?
Right here with the sweater on?
What you do?
You act and you draw.
All right.
What you, right here
sister what you go?
>> I act and I play the horn.
>> Jason Reynolds:
You play the horn.
I used to play the horn.
What you got brother?
>> I draw and I play --
>> Jason Reynolds:
You drawing right now?
>> Yeah.
>> Jason Reynolds:
Get him out of there.
All right, what you go?
>> I draw and I play the piano.
>> Jason Reynolds:
You play the piano.
In the back, what you got?
>> I work hard.
>> Jason Reynolds: You work hard.
Boom. Drop the mic; she like
-- I work hard, word up.
What you got sister, right here.
>> Acting.
>> Jason Reynolds: You act.
Right here.
>> I write poetry.
>> Jason Reynolds: You write poetry.
Ain't no rappers in here?
There's always a rapper in the room.
You a rapper?
You MC? All right, let
me ask you all this.
Let me -- hold, hold, hold.
The one dude who put his hand up
got bars -- let me ask you all this.
Let me ask you all this.
Who you all listening to, right?
If you're a rapper, let's talk
about it and it keep it 100 with me.
Don't yell out, don't
yell out, don't yell out.
Don't yell out.
all right, who you got?
Who you listening to?
Who you got?
What'd he say?
[ Inaudible ]
>> Jason Reynolds: I got to
look it up; I don't even know.
What you got?
>> Kendrick Lamar.
>> Jason Reynolds: Kendrick Lamar.
What you got?
>> Drake.
>> Jason Reynolds:
Drake, what you got?
Nobody, I don't listen to music.
What you got?
Who you got.
I can't hear what she's saying?
>> Chief Keef.
>> Jason Reynolds: Chief Keef.
Who you got?
Big Fluf? I don't know who that is.
I'll look it up you
know what I mean?
Yeah? Who is it?
Shy Glizzy, he's from D.C., right?
[ Inaudible ]
>> Jason Reynolds: All
right, what you got?
Comment. You like old --
Comment my generation;
you too young to think
about Comment.
Comment an actor now.
What you go?
>> Feddy Wopp.
>> Feddy Wopp, right?
All right, so here's the question.
So here's the question,
here's the question;
here's why that's important.
Here's why that's important, right?
Here's why that's important;
so all you all artists.
Everybody in here like "I'm an
actor, I'm a writer, I'm a poet,
I work hard" you know
what I'm saying?
Like whatever your art is.
The [Inaudible] you all
threw out to me right?
You got Feddy Wopp,
I'm good with it.
Feddy Wopp, quality music
you know what I mean?
I got Drake.
I got Shy Glizzy, who is it?
Little herb.
I got Chief Keef, right.
Who is this guy?
Who is this?
>> Brendan Kiely: I'm
looking this up tonight.
>>Jason Reynolds: I know,
they yelling it at me.
I'm supposed to know and
I'm like "I don't know".
All right, so here's the deal.
Everybody that we named, of
everybody that we named how many
of them, how many of them
have songs about this?
About police brutality?
So, but you ain't named J. Cole.
You named Kendrick, so we got
Kendrick and you named Comment.
So we got 10 names, you all got
Keef, you all got Shy Glizzy,
you all got Little herb you
all got somebody named slightly
or something.
You all got --
>> Jason Reynolds: You all
got Drake; so what that --
hey so what that means,
so what that means is,
what that means is --
don't get me wrong.
It's okay, party music is
what's up; I'm with it, right?
But it's important that we know that
if you guys are going to be artists
and if your artists of today aren't
doing their job in terms of talking
about the things that are important,
it's okay that they make party
music, because we need to party too.
But somebody has to
do the work, right?
You work hard, my girl who is
the artist says "I work hard".
Well look we got to make
sure that we work hard
on what's necessary to work hard on.
Right? If we can party all day, if
we can do what time to be a live
and we can party and all
those things, that's cool.
Let's just make sure that
you guys grow into artists
that you realize you
have responsibilities.
Because if nobody tells your
story then it doesn't exist.
No one will ever know.
No one can give it any value.
So, Brendan and I can write
this book and give it to you
and hope you read it and say "Like
it's okay that Drake ain't talking
about it", Kendrick -- well
Kendrick is talking about it, right?
But Glizzy ain't talking about it.
Fat Trail ain't talking
about it, right?
Whoever it is that you
all rock with, right?
But at least there's something that
exists, at least there's something
that exists that's
talking about it and --
>> Brendan Kiely: And this
is an invitation for you.
Right? This book is also
an invitation for you.
This is an invitation for you
to have these conversations
and start close.
Make sure you're having those
conversations with your friends.
Ask your teachers to
have these conversations.
I think it's really
important to think
about this as a team effort, right?
This book -- I can't
write this book by myself.
I'd be an idiot if I thought I could
do that for a lot of reasons, right?
I can't do that.
It's a team effort.
It's a team effort for a reason.
I think we would all
do ourselves a favor
if we took this invitation
to create teams right?
There's that old saying, right?
Like a network is a net, right?
It doesn't work if it's
just one person, it's a net.
You've got to build
the network, right?
This -- we want this book to
be a tool for you to begin
to have real conversations,
really honest conversations.
Like why does the White guy
want to talk about this?
Right? We want to have these
super honest conversations
and you've got to start close.
And build out.
>> Jason Reynolds: You have
a question right there,
you should take it.
What's up man?
>> Brendan Kiely: How
we doing on time?
[ Inaudible ]
>> Brendan Kiely: Let shoot
with a question, yeah?
[ Inaudible ]
>> Jason Reynolds:
So the question is --
the question was why are people
defined by the color of their skin?
And not by -- why are people
The truth is, is that
people shouldn't be.
Right? That's the truth.
That's the issue.
You know that's the issue.
The reality is that everybody
in this room, we're all one.
Everybody here talking
about the same things,
we're all in the same space
having the same experience, right?
Having a good time.
Everybody wanting to go home
and see their brothers
and sisters, you know?
Talk to their mama, talk to
their pops, have some dinner.
Whatever it is you all
do, you know what I mean?
But everybody, whatever
it is you do,
everybody in here wants the
same -- that's how it is.
We got the same fears, we
got the same struggles.
We think the same things
are funny most of the time.
And so the issue is
that people shouldn't --
people shouldn't feel like
race is such a big deal.
Unfortunately, historically --
unfortunately if I'm going to
be completely honest with you,
historically this country was
sort of predicated and built
on that construct, right?
The racial construct.
I know you guys study it in school.
I hope you study it
in school in terms
of you know slavery and
all of these things.
It doesn't mean it has to
exist today or that it needs
to exist today, but it still does.
And while it does we have
work to do, you know?
>> Brendan Kiely: I want to try to
answer that question honestly too
because I think it's important to --
as Jason is talking about it like it
shouldn't be and yet that happens.
That is the case and for us
to pretend otherwise would be
doing everybody a disservice.
So to think about that historical
construct that is at the root,
we're talking about slavery, right?
We're talking about this construct
in our society, in our country.
It is embedded in our history.
It would be a lie; I think
it would be a like to pretend
like that doesn't affect
our lives today.
And so in our book one of the
things that we're trying to talk
about is how that's
connected in fact.
Why is it the case that Quinn,
the White character is thinking
for the first time in
his life that he's White,
like what it means to be White.
That's a weird, that's
a strange thing, right?
It's a strange thing for someone
to say out loud in his world.
But it would be a lie to
say that it's not part
of hour our society works.
So, we have to be honest first and
then I think we work from there.
Does that make sense?
Yeah, it's a good question.
What else?
Let's start in the back,
because we always get to the
[ Inaudible ]
>> This is for Jason; when you sit
down and start to write the book,
did you get emotional and how did
you get over that emotional feeling?
>> Jason Reynolds:
Yeah, so good question.
So, when I sat down to write the
book I was, it's funny, right?
At the time I -- at the time before
I started writing it I wasn't
as emotional.
Because I hadn't really
thought about it, right?
I thought about Trayvon, I
thought about Mike Brown.
It was all sort of bubbling, but
it was still sort of at a distance
and because we had gone through this
so many times before you all
were born, I had already gone
through this a lot of times, right?
And so at some point you
start to unfortunately it --
you start to shake it
off a little quicker,
which is really --
it's a terrible thing.
It's like anybody -- it's like
people who have experienced death,
if you've experienced a
lot of death in your family
and someone else dies, it hurts but
only for a moment and you're like
"That's what happens,
its life", right?
And so at the time I wasn't
really feeling any kind of way.
But when I started to write
it and when I really started
to think about what was going on.
I was broken down, it was terrible.
It was terrible.
And I started to think about things
that we don't think about, right?
So a prime example,
social media, right?
Now here's the thing.
I think social media is a
powerful, powerful thing.
It's what spawned sort of "Black
Lives Matter" and all these things
that are happening now it's
come from like camera phones
and posting it to the
social media sites.
But what we never stopped to
think about in the midst of all
of that is the family
members of the people
who -- of the people who died.
So let's say you're
Trayvon Martin's mother
or you're Trayvon Martin's
little brother.
And every time you go online
you see like 10,000 posts
about what happened to your brother.
Every time you turn the news on,
you see the news people playing
on loop what happened
to your brother.
Every time you're on Facebook
or Twitter or Snapchat
or whatever it is you see, there's
hashtags with your brother's name
on it millions of people,
the constant sort of reminder
of what has happened
to your loved one.
So I was thinking about
like the family members too.
And what if Mike Browns mom
feels knowing for a fact
that every single time she gets
on the internet her sons picture,
his footage, the footage
of his murder,
his dead body on the
street is played over
and over and over and over again.
What does that feel like?
And those things sort of broke
me down and those things sort
of made me feel some kind
of way; so good question.
Thank you.
[ Inaudible ]
>> All right, I said who
do you look up to and why?
>> Jason Reynolds: You.
I look up to you homey.
You work -- you said you work
hard, that's all I'm looking for.
That's all I ever wanted
to do was be a hard worker.
Everything I got in life, I
got from hard work, right?
So I'm looking at you.
I'm looking at all you all.
Listen everybody outside
these rooms,
in case you all didn't know
looking at you all crazy.
People always say -- I talk to
elders and older people all the time
and like "Look I don't
know about this generation.
I don't know".
But I talk to you guys
face to face every day.
And what I know is you all the most
brilliant kids that every lived.
You all doing big things,
but you all have to know
that in order for it to matter.
So, I'm looking up to you all,
which means you all
got to not let me down.
Feel me? All right.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Brendan Kiely: Let's
get a couple more in
and then we'll go to the cards.
Yeah?
>> Why did you name the
book All American Boys?
Because it's not just
only boys getting killed.
>> Brendan Kiely: That's
a great question.
So Jason rightly had the first --
he wrote the first email back to
our editor when we were talking
about this title, to say this is
not just a problem that boys suffer.
This is a problem that
girls suffer as well.
It is true that in the book if you
read into the story and begin to see
who are the people who are
involved in the protests,
you'll see that girls
are involved as well.
And you'll see that there's some
conversation about that in the book.
But I think your question
is a really great question
because this idea of
all American boys,
has anyone ever heard
that term before?
Like an all American boy?
Yeah. You what?
Like a cowboy?
Right, that image of a -- so
somehow there's that association
in our mind, an all American
boy is a cowboy, right?
So I guess in my mind, in my
mind teaching in New York City,
teaching in classes where there are
people whose first language is --
they're over 180 different
languages, right?
People from all over the
world are in these schools
where I was teaching in
New York City, right?
And I'm thinking these are all
American Boys and girls, right?
So there's a real issue
out there in the world
if we think immediately
of that cowboy, right?
Because believe me, I do too.
I'm right with you.
That was my first instinct.
But we want to make sure
that everyone is talking
about why is that our instinct?
That's why we have All American
Boys as the title, right?
Because we want to open that up.
It should include all of us.
It's a term that shouldn't
just be that first association.
So that's an awesome question.
We have some others
on the cards as well.
I want to do justice to some
of the folks who wrote cards.
Because you know when
you're in class the people
who are the loudest always get to
-- you know get their answers first?
So let's go to the people who
actually wrote some questions down.
And one of the questions that I saw
in the deck was about the two of us
and writing and when we started.
So, I just want to address some of
the birth of art kind of questions.
I will be honest with you,
when I was in high school I had
a high school teacher tell me
that I wasn't so great.
I'm not kidding.
That I was not so great at writing.
It was something that I loved.
I -- believe it or not I actually
liked quite a bit of hip hop too
when I was in middle school and
that was my intro into poetry.
And then I learned a lot more about
poetry and I was moving forward
and I said, "Look I want
to do some creative work".
My high school teacher said,
"No you're not so great".
That was a real -- that
was a real push for me
because I cared about it.
So I started writing and I started
writing and I started writing
and I failed and I failed
and I can't tell you how empowering
that was for me to keep at it.
>>Jason Reynolds: I have
a similar story though.
Here's the thing right?
So people always ask like "When
did you start", "Why do you write",
"Were you writing your whole life",
"Were you reading a bunch of books"?
I didn't read any books
until I was 17.
Zero, no novels.
No -- you guys have
already read books.
I read no books until I was
17 because back in the 80's
and 90's All American
Boys didn't exist.
Those books, it wasn't
happening, right?
We had Walter D. Myers, thankfully.
Did any of you all
know Walter D. Myers,
has anyone heard of Walter D. Myers?
The great Walter D. Myers.
So, we had Walter D. Myers right,
so if you were a kid growing up,
in a black neighborhood or with a
black family and that kind of thing,
he was pretty much one of
the only ones representing
for the younger people telling
their stories for the most part.
And so I went all through school
without ever reading anything.
Lord of the Flies, To Kill a
Mockingbird, Of Mice and Men,
I just was like "I'm not reading
it; I'm not doing any of that".
Like "Just give me a
C, let me move on".
I'm not doing it.
So, what saved me was the same
thing, it was Queen Latifah, yo.
Queen Latifah because back
in the day before Queen Latifah
was an actress, and a model
and a TV show host and all
this, that and the third.
Queen Latifah was a rapper, I
don't know if you all knew that.
Queen Latifah, not only was
she a rapper, she was like one
of the best rappers around.
All you young ladies,
it don't matter.
If you got balls, you got balls.
Latifah was amazing and so I
remember going to the store
and buying Queen Latifah's album
and taking the plastic off,
it was a cassette tape.
You all know what cassette
tapes, all right?
I was just trying to make sure.
What's a cassette tape?
>> Them little tapes.
>> Jason Reynolds:
Them little tapes.
That's where mix tape --
you know all you be talking
about a mix tape came out, that
was what a mix tape actually was.
There ain't no such thing
as a mix tape no more
because tapes don't exist anymore.
But that's what a mix
tape was, right?
That's where they come
from, like actual tapes.
We had to like, we
call them pause tapes.
You had to sit at a
radio and hit record.
And like -- ask your parents
about it, you know what I mean?
So Queen Latifah had this album
come out called Black Rain,
and I bought this record
and this was the one
where UNITY, UNITY, right?
And so I bought the album.
I take the plastic off and back then
every single album you bought came
with these things called
liner notes.
And I know you all don't
know what no liner notes are.
But what they were, were
basically pamphlets that came
in every single cassette tape.
A little teeny pamphlet was this big
but you could unfold it and it was
like this long, all right?
So you unfold it and
what was printed
on the pamphlet were the
lyrics to every single song.
I wish -- had they had
that with nothing coming --
ain't nothing on paper no more.
It come with the album,
you can tap the album?
>> You have to download.
>> Jason Reynolds: You got to
download it, who want to do that?
You all download liner notes?
No. You know what I mean.
So and if you all did download
liner notes and read the lyrics,
most of you all --
they'd lose a lot of fans
because don't nobody know
what Future talking about
and if you all could
read it you'd all be like
"I don't know what he's saying".
He's saying nothing.
He's mumbling.
And we paying my man
for him to mumble.
But anyway, so I got Queen
Latifah, Queen Latifah's album.
I listened to the whole
record, right?
The whole album and then
I listened to it again
but this time I was reading
along with the lyrics.
And then the third time I just
read the lyrics by themselves.
I was like 10 years old and it was
the first time I read it and I was
like "Oh man, all this stuff
they teaching me in school
about like Langston Hughes and these
people, Queen Latifah was doing sort
of the same thing, except
it was connecting with me.
And we had Pac right?
Pac was a poet, right?
We had Slick Rick;
Slick Rick was a poet.
Right, we had [Inaudible], we had
Kool Moe Dee, we had Karis One,
we had all these people and
we had early Jay-Z, back in --
these people considered
themselves poets.
And so studying hip hop for
the course of like my childhood
and all the way up through
college is what got me into writing
because all I wanted to do was
tell stories about what it was
like to be me, and tell stories
about my family and my friends
and my community because that's
what the rappers were doing.
And then eventually I
discovered Richard Wright
and it changed my life
and that was it.
>> Brendan Kiely: Just one more from
the cards because there are a number
of questions that are similar;
so just to address a
couple more of these.
And I'm just going to read
a couple of these out loud
because you wrote them and when
I used to teach I used to --
when I handed papers back, I
used to like to read aloud lines
from the papers that students had
written just to say "Look this is --
we're ready this aloud, just like
we're reading our books aloud
because you guys have
done some great work".
And so I appreciate just some
of these questions quite a bit.
Here's a series of questions in a
row that I think are all related.
How does police brutality
effect how you act
when you walk around outside?
And how does it affect how you feel
about being put in your own skin?
How does police brutality
affect those around you
and how does it affect your friends?
How does your personal view
of police brutality
affect your relationships
with your friends who
thought differently?
And that's a question that I really,
really appreciate quite a bit.
This, this idea of how I
might feel about this, right?
About how I feel about
police brutality.
I don't want to pretend that I
am someone who is also a victim.
I want to instead ask the question
what can I do to help stop this.
What's my role in this conversation?
And I think it's inspiring
to think back
to all the marches
of last year, right?
I think it's inspiring to think
about how this was not a series
of marches that were started
by politicians, right?
These are things that grew
out of people who lived
in the neighborhoods where
this was all happening.
And so my role, I feel like, is
to support those who begin some
of these movements, to help try
to inspire some of this protest,
to help inspire some
of this antagonism
and to join people when
they get out there.
And to make sure that when
I'm walking down the street
and I see something going on,
like maybe for example I see
something happening down the road
and it's not necessarily a friend
of mine, but I just might make sure
that I don't turn this time.
Maybe I stay and watch, maybe I
pull out my phone, maybe I recognize
that I am not a bystander.
You've heard that phrase, right?
Don't be a bystander,
be an upstander?
Right? As corny as that sounds,
I believe that is so true.
And so I appreciate these questions
because I think it's important
for us all to recognize what we
can do in different situations.
My role because of that
awful story that I told,
right is that I might have that
privilege to stand in the street
and help make sure that
others see what's going on.
And so I encourage
people to use power
when they have it, in the right way.
>> Jason Reynolds: And for me,
you know the question
of what it feels like.
Honest answer, it feels normal.
And that's a problem.
It feels normal for me.
It feels normal for
a lot of us I think.
And so what I'm tasking
you all to do is
to just let your voices be heard.
Be aware, right?
This isn't about you
hating police officers,
because all cops aren't bad cops.
That's the truth, right?
That's not what we're telling you.
That's ridiculous.
That's not -- not all cops are bad.
There are good cops.
Some of you have called cops and
they've come and helped you, right?
What I'm saying is just be aware
that these things are happening.
If you are growing up and want to
be a police officer, be a good cop.
You have an opportunity
to change things too.
There's hope in you.
We're looking at you like
you guys can be the future,
you guys can help, make your voices
hears, let your voices be heard.
Don't be afraid you know?
Don't feel ashamed.
Don't feel the need to have
to walk a different way.
Be who you are and push for a
better day, push for something more.
Have these conversations,
talk to police officers
when they're not sort
of doing their thing.
When they're not sort of
working in -- or in action.
Walk up to a cop and ask him
questions, some fair questions.
Have some discourse,
especially in your communities.
If you've got beat cops in your
neighborhood, which are the cops
who patrol the street, just
hanging out on your block and stuff.
They in your neighborhood,
say "What's up?
How you doing"?
Create relationships,
it's what we need.
How much time do we have?
I want to make sure --
>> Why don't we take
two more questions,
maybe one in the audience and --
>> Jason Reynolds:
Perfect, it's your call man.
>> Brendan Kiely: Who has
not yet had a chance to --
we got this one over here in
the glasses, right over here.
>> Jason Reynolds:
And the [Inaudible].
We ain't doing that well though.
[ Inaudible ]
>> What inspired you to
buy Queen Latifah's album?
>> Jason Reynolds: What inspired
me to buy Queen Latifah's album?
Yo it's hard to explain it
because at the time
everybody was buying Queen --
it's the same thing that inspires
all you all to buy Drake, right?
She was Drake of her time.
She was a big deal man
and she was saying things
about the neighborhoods.
So, like what she was
saying literally was like
"Look this is how we living around
here, this is what's going on".
She was telling boys to
respect girls, right?
In a time where you know no one
was saying it like that, right?
Because we had Salt N
Peppa out at the same time,
and they were doing the same
thing, but in a different way.
Latifah was like "Look I'm
big enough and I'm bad enough
to beat you, so you not about
to come at me like that",
what was her whole thing.
And for some reason, I don't know
if it's because I have a sister
and for some reason I
was really attracted
to like her message and
what she was saying.
And she just had -- she
was just a beast with it.
She was so good, and so
that's why Latifah, yeah.
>> Brendan Kiely: Let's sneak in
one more over there, in the coat.
Yeah.
>> Did the book ever make an
impact on your daily life?
>> Brendan Kiely: Did this book?
>> Yeah.
>> Jason Reynolds: We right here.
This is an impact on
our daily lives.
As of today this is the impact.
>> Brendan Kiely: No, you know why
I appreciate that is because I feel,
I feel really lucky that I get
to do something I care about.
And I spent a lot of
time doing things
that I didn't kind
of really care about.
And so I got this opportunity; so
yes this book has made that impact.
but also I think the book makes an
impact because you know we stand
on stage, and we talk as if we're
expects of some kind or another
And I want to be clear that I
don't feel like I'm an expert.
My role and why I feel really lucky
to be a part of this project is just
to get out there and
do something, right?
I don't want to make a
claim that I'm an expert,
so the book makes an impact on
my life every day because I want
to learn a little bit
more every day.
>> Jason Reynolds: Same here.
>> Okay, thank you guys.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you so much
Jason and Brendan.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.